belle gabrielle et j'ai un problème je
ne peux pas résister une fin prévue je
bossais sur des vrais cas moi septembre
avec le pas résisté aux femmes c'est le
problème de 90% la population masculine
comment comptez vous gérer votre
relation avec moi peux pas vous le
cacher les jolie brune au regard
pétillant et szczesny enchaîné mais
aussi pourquoi pas enchaîner poursuivi
alors vous avez des choses au clair déjà
les hommes qui souffrent de votre
pathologie s'imagine toujours que toutes
les femmes veulent coucher avec eux et
puis sans vouloir vous vexer vous avez
un sourire un peu ni voilà c'est lui la
malle gabriel j'ai un problème je ne
peux pas résister une femme c'est plus
fort que moi il se passe un phénomène
physique je suis une espèce d'amour
permanent non faut qu'on me fasse rire
un client arrive avec une addiction par
élève
si vous pouvez pas résister aux femmes
comment comptez vous gérer votre
relation avec moi je vais pas vous le
cacher les jolie brune au regard
pétillant et ancenis enchaîné mais aussi
pourquoi pas siné poursuivi
je vous observe et 24h 24 non mais c'est
pas possible je vis avec mon tonton jaws
sa femme l'a quitté il ya deux ans et
demi c'est pas négociable
hors de question derrière aucune femme
ne rentre ici pas dans le temple on va
les y entraient je vous montrez votre
chambre enfin ma chance et vous bah je
me disais comme le litre est grand on va
pas se gêner
ok on va complètement jeune et je vais
dormir sur le canapé on veut pas se
permettre des jo sans un sourire ou le
soir qu'il parlerait jamais oui elle m'a
giflé avec ces niches on appelle ça
comment toi et qui fut un des gifles au
plafond j'ai tout essayé je sais plus
quoi faire
on a rencontré son assistante elle a
l'air bon pas bon que compétente faut
quand même que c'était les quatre là bas
seul m
ça va pas gd sur le hockey c'est quoi sa
femme je ne veux que du professionnel
plus pour être sûr vous allez perdre
votre t-shirt
c'est vrai je connais pas un peu plus de
temps je sais pas si vous avez quelque
chose de prévu
[Applaudissements]
star
tu te rends compte que depuis qu'elle
s'occupe de moi j'ai pas séduit une
seule fille
un très bon test je ne saurais pas vous
contrôlez et je peux contrôler
maintenant